freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge ein tag persönlicher kommt
heute mit riesen himself
das heißt natürlich auch einen tag lang
legal kaufen und sondern man ganz
ehrlich ihr selbst verhängt auch dahin
halb neun
ja das war nicht ganz so gutes wort
einlegen mit dass meine kamera wiederum
gesponnen hat er das ding ist die kamera
war das nicht schuld aber max volbers
schuld also schiebt alles komplett auf
markt trägt auch ein ganz bitteres
richtig eine art weil der todes weg und
alles was wir jetzt gleich seht das
werden wir nach sprechen aus dem auf was
wir dann grob gesagt haben macht das
ganze einfach in perfekter schauspieler
arbeit von vorne los geht's mit dem
frühstück es gab bananen schoko pancakes
assoziierung sehr lecker noch mal leute
es tut mir mega light neue kamera ist
schon gekauft ich erkläre ich im laufe
des video wie das immer passieren kann
aber erst mal zu den zutaten wir haben
mandelmilch pflanzliches öl dann haben
wir cacau schoko perlen backpulver zimt
und dann kann es auch schon losgehen wie
bei fast jedem pancake rezept haben wir
eine trockene und eine flüssige ball
mitnehmen zwei sehr sehr reife bananen
ich habe extra welche reifen lassen für
das video und geben die in eine schüssel
hinein verlängern die ganz gut mit einer
gabel damit sie wirklich wieso ein püree
sind dann habe ich das ganze auf eine
waage gestellt und habe 500 milliliter
mandelmilch ungesüßte darauf gegeben
manche passt super zu banane ihr könnt
aber auch jeder andere ungesüßte
pflanzen mitnimmt darauf kommen dann
fünf esslöffel öl neutrales öl
sonnenblumenöl und dann wird alles ganz
fein verrührt kommen wir zum trockenen
teil da geben wir 400 gramm mehl in eine
schüssel hinein
dazu kommen sechs esslöffel zucker
aber die mädchen gesüßt dann vier
esslöffel kakaopulver und zwei esslöffel
backpulver dann habe ich mir auch schon
ein bisschen vegane butter geschnappt
und habe zwei boxern heiß werden lassen
einfach weil die pancakes relativ lange
zum ausbacken brauchen habe ich direkt
mit zwei fanden losgelegt noch ein
bisschen zimt in die schüssel hinein
eine prise salz alles fein verquirlen
dabei ihr seht schon ist am schrauben
doch schon super super lecker wenn man
wer angefangen langsam den flüssigen
teil unter den trockenen zu rühren ganz
wichtig wie bei allen pancakes
eigentlich nicht über mixen also leicht
messen und schauen dass das ganze super
flüssig bleibt dürfen paar kleine
klumpen drin sein
jetzt habe ich so zwei große löffel von
unserem teich hineingegeben er ist sehr
dickflüssig sehr zäh
das trägt wie gesagt dazu bei dass die
schönen hoch werden dafür dass er kein
ei drin oder sonst was sind die wirklich
heftig heftig dick oben kommt die zart
bitterschokolade drauf wir backen das
ganze aus und es ist einfach super super
lecker und hübsch anzusehen die fertigen
pancakes habe ich da nur noch im ofen
waren gehalten einen schönen turm daraus
gebaut und das ganze noch schön mit
bananen und ahornsirup garniert und dann
war es soweit dann habe ich die pancakes
reingebracht bruder ein moment denn du
niemals vergessen ist sodann war es sehr
höchst mehrere schichten also wirklich
pancake also mit wie ein kuchen mehrere
schichten dazwischen die bananen
schreiben obendrauf noch der zero darin
noch die kleinen schokostückchen diese
leicht verlaufen sind nicht flüssig aber
so leicht so cremig ja das gefühl es
könnte ihr geschmeckt haben aber wie das
bei mir immer so ist gegen erst die
kamera aus dann war wieder da ich habe
mich gefragt welches ihr geschmeckt hat
weiß man das so gesagt hat ja was ich
gesagt habe war irgendwie genau was ich
gesagt habe auf jeden fall dass mir sehr
gut geschmeckt der jagst du sowas
gleichen bor
ist das geil oder krass alter aber das
auch nur die hälfte vom stapel geschafft
weil ja einfach so mächtig war gehabt
wer eigentlich fallen ja du hast morgen
auf jeden fall auch mal was einem staat
ja ich habe es danach ins office
gebracht um die haben
was war das ganze in der not für dich in
der note habe ich gesagt dass es eine
8,7 ist nicht schlecht ja es ist nicht
mehr es ist nicht neu aber es ist schon
sehr sehr gut aber nicht erstens zu sein
etwas schwächeren 9
da war ich auf jeden fall ganz zufrieden
wenn leute aber und ihr mal klare
mittagessen dem ich alles und das in dem
ich anfange vier schalotten superfeinen
zu würfeln leute ich wollte euch ja noch
erklären was los ist wieso passiert das
mit dem audio immer meine kamera hat
keinen flip screen die ist eigentlich
super gut aber ich drehe meine videos
alleine mit einem stativ deshalb kann
ich nicht sehen was auf der kamera
upgrade ich kann nicht sehen wenn das
mikro nicht funktioniert oder so hirsch
witzig übrigens die charlotte ein
bisschen an gibt reinhard gramm risotto
reis dazu der wird ebenfalls
angeschwitzt ende vom lied ich habe eine
neue kamera ab dem ersten 17 habe ich
sofort beim videos filmen und es wird
alles besser ich glaube ich reg mich
selbst am meisten darüber auf aber ich
kann es auch verstehen wenn ihr sagt ey
kriegt das nochmal auf die kette
erziehung mache ich versprochen das
ganze löschen wir es mit einem
großzügigen schluck weißwein ab den
lassen wir komplett verkaufen bzw
lassen ihnen vom risotto aufnehmen
darauf kommen 600 milliliter wasser und
ein esslöffel gemüsebrühe sozusagen 600
milliliter brühe ein wenig satt rankommt
noch dran und dann lassen wir das ganze
einfach stehen und köcheln bis die ganze
flüssigkeit aufgenommen ist
selbstverständlich kriegen unsere
arancino auch eine füllung und zwar
veganes ragout dafür brauche ich veganes
hackfleisch erst mal drüben gebe ich
noch ein wenig butter in den topf und
dann kommt auch das vegane hackfleisch
in die pfanne und wird knusprig
angebratenen die butter vegane butter
natürlich wird untergerührt das sind so
ungefähr 80 gramm und das hackfleisch
krieg richtig schön restauriert wird
heiß angebraten und dann kommt eine dose
gehackten tomaten drauf die lassen wir
schön verkaufen dass er gar nicht viel
flüssigkeit haben ein paar erbsen noch
dazu aus der tiefkühltruhe
das resort lokal noch ein bisschen wie
schmecken das tagoe ab
lasst uns fertig köchin damit wir unser
veganes risotto zu arancino
weiterverarbeiten können muss erst mal
alles schön abkühlen ich habe das dafür
einfach auch so dreht am verteilt
ausgestrichen schön dünn
erst mal kurz auf den balkon gestellt
und dann in die gefriertruhe 2 liter öl
in den mittleren topf waren gemacht dann
habe ich mir quasi so eine ecke immer
von dem risotto genommen in die mitte
das war gut gepackt und das ganze
geschlossen überschüssiges weggenommen
und das ganze schön zu arancino geformt
pannierstraße durchlaufen lassen mail
zweite station ersatz 150 milliliter
wasser 50 gramm stärke 50 gramm mehl und
am ende hält kramp dann hab ich das
ganze einfach ins heiße öl gelegt und
für circa acht minuten goldbraun
blubbern das und so sieht das endprodukt
aus kann sich wirklich sehen lassen aber
hat es auch geschmeckt
[Musik]
nun da waren sie die apache nie komplett
veganer überrascht wie gut es
funktioniert hat und ehrlich zu sein ich
habe vergessen diese hat noch nie ein
genie probiert überhaupt weilmünster
über zehn jahren legal da ich genau
sowas gibts ja normalerweise mit klatsch
genau das gibt sind fleisch mit käse
meinen werken ja quasi auch so ein
ragout drin mit veganem hat aber das
habe ich selbst auch noch nicht gesehen
auf den street und makler so dass in
vegas oder deshalb war schon sehr
braucht es dir zeigen zu können
und der erste biss war ja auch nicht
unbedingt falsch jetzt schon leichter
gefeiert habe ich sehr abgefallen also
das definitiv sehr sehr krass ich will
das unbedingt wieder haben du musst
unbedingt wiederkommen und wieder machen
da mal sagen wie es geht erstmal liegen
kamera aus stimmt weil man weiß ja gar
nicht wenn wir wieder da die teller sind
aufgegessen
und wer hat's geschmeckt gut sättigen
zwei stellen so dass auch zwischen
gestern und heute als super mario war
echt lecker was war das für eine note
bei dir
es war eine 9,3 also noch besser als die
pancakes es ist schon ist sehr hoch so
als ja da gibt es da gibt es kaum was
was noch keiner soll das finde ich aber
auch gut wir wirklich immer nachgedacht
es gibt leute machen aus dem bauch
heraus würde ich selbst auch immer
machen weiß wer du bist sehr überlegt
angegangen und dann weiß ich umso mehr
93 zu schätzen
aber da sage ich ehrlich sollte war mein
ehrgeiz das wirklich geweckt fürs
abendessen
da gibt es nämlich black bean smash
bürger und wie ich das gemacht habe
jetzt so wir sind zog aus dem rostocker
leute ich weiß wo ich bin guter dinge
aber wir machen black bean smash klingt
sehr nice ist hoffentlich auch sehr nice
und ich habe bereits vorbereitet 250
gramm schwarze bohnen er habe ich so
gekauft war sie in getrockneter form was
habe ich damit gemacht ein mal
aufgekocht wird zwei minuten dann eigene
stunde stehen lassen ausgespült
abgespült und dann nochmal für
eineinhalb stunden köcheln lassen
das ist ein bisschen unter kocht würde
man sagen das wollen wir allerdings weil
wir wollen dass sie trocken sind das
auch der grund dass man sich die arbeit
machen mit selbst bauen bleibe aber will
man sie aus einer dose einfach nehmen
werden sie halt eben komplett integriert
und würden nicht so gut zusammenhalten
für unsere masse aus der wir dann die
tagesform
nein und zu den bohnen kommen noch ein
paar von den pankow brems und zwar so
circa 20 grad mehr als man denken würde
dass wir auch dazu zwecke braucht
geht aber darum dass die quasi grob
zerkleinert werden unter so einem ewige
textur bekommen aber dann gehen wir das
ganze hier in eine schüssel so also die
textur ist jetzt so dass das alles gut
zusammenhält aber noch nicht super viel
bände kraft hat aber darum kümmern wir
uns jetzt dann gehen wir dazu ein wenig
pfeffer rundlicher und außerdem ein
wenig von unseren geliebten
geschmacksverstärkern
das hilft dem ganzen mehr diesen humane
geschmackliche geschmacks kontinente zu
dem niederwald auch wieder zu macht das
ist harmlos so dann hab ich hier jetzt
ein ersatz wir müssen nämlich quasi ein
hinzufügen dabei der verbrauch 5,8 und
sprudelwasser hoffe ganz oft
funktioniert was muss ich sagen
persönlich beladen seid könnt ihr
natürlich auch einfach mitnehmen dann
geben wir einen teil von unseren ersatz
hinein und vermischen das ganze schon
mal mit den händen menschen darunter
einfach so können jetzt anhalt an die
gewünschte text uhr heran arbeiten also
findet auf jeden fall schon deutlich
mehr daran die bis jetzt noch einen
wenigen maisstärke haben zwei teelöffel
dem ganzen noch mal mehr bindekraft und
jetzt hält das ganze auch schon zusammen
so dann würde es jetzt auch zeit unsere
tipps zu fahren
wie gesagt wir brauchen etwa 60 gramm
pro welche 65 darauf mir dass sie dass
es sehr gut aus und daraus formen der
eben eine kugel wäre dann platz meschen
können so haben wir unsere welchen so
ich komme ich noch die weiteren toppings
für den bürger dann nehmen wir eine
schöne dicke fleischtomate zur iso kopf
jetzt schon gleich deshalb schmeiße ich
hier schon mal an ich nehme übrigens
zwei weil logischerweise bis auf zwei
partie ist gleichzeitig mit einem mario
fritzsche senf ketchup außerdem schnäbel
ich auch eine kleine zwiebel rein und
fangen
mal erdnussöl hinein dann geben wir
zwiebel in eine schüssel und dann
gleiche teile sind mario catcher kommt
dann nicht dazu mit habe ich noch was
anderes vor
ein großzügiges heimat alles verbinden
das haben wir immer noch gurken wasser
oder sushi special sauce von jedem
einzelnen bürger das tor war so ich habe
die partie jetzt hinein ist nicht die
haben zwei drei minuten pro seite
gekocht es ist zeit für uns sie zu
wenden sie sich schon die haben
tatsächlich bisschen farbe bekommt und
jetzt gehen wir in die mitte zwei
schreiben von unserem veganen käseersatz
und packen dann einfach schön auf die
oberseite unser zweites partie drauf
steht gleich nur noch eine komponente
für unseren bürger hier schmeckt der
käse aus und in der anderen seite fertig
schmerzen bereit alles fertig wir nehmen
unser gekostet s-bahn team auf die
unterseite und ich war es von unserer
veganen burger soße
darauf kommt ein wenig kredite salat
dann von unserer fleischtomate das
mcbean perry und oben und top privater
mit ein paar rest wie willen habe ich
mir noch gedacht dass menschen dienen
[Musik]
so das sind auf ein abendessen
ausnahmsweise diesmal nicht nach
gesprochen und wir haben einen black
bean smethurst ich habe keine ahnung
dass er dazu bereit
also wirklich weist sind sehr gut ja ich
bin auch nicht falsch ich weiß aber halt
noch gar nicht was da und so erwartet
ich finde der käse mit dem muss man ganz
kurz mal wertschätzen du siehst du das
hier auseinander sofort komplett
auseinander fällt
die diese black bean
sie haben nicht so feste struktur ja
aber so trocken aber sind sechs klubs
von komplett alles auseinander
sowieso ist die letzten kabel in den
letzten bissen in der burger war nicht
ganz stabil ist ein bisschen auseinander
gefallen aber ich hoffe er war trotzdem
stabil
boston muss bewährten ja wir hatten ja
die ersten bewertung war ja eine kommune
komma 7 die zweite darf meine 9,3 also
von den acht kinos arancino menschen und
das hier hat im grunde genommen nur
minuspunkte durch die instabilität des
des mannes ok habe ich dann natürlich
der ganze bürger auch ein bisschen
instabiler wird war aber ein protein
ball habe ich ja schon weg war ja gut
hin wann also deswegen die maschine ist
man auf jeden fall krasser die waren
einfach die waren einfach vollkommen
krass ist nur die frage wo muss ich es
ansetzen weil ansonsten war der bürger
mega da war christie flair drin saucen
krass super krass und alleine das ist
dann schon ich meine was wenn du kein
geiles gefühl das plus geile saucen dann
ist ein bürger ja schon
es ist schon die halbe miete sondern wir
schon sehr sehr geil gewesen aber die
stabilität von dem bann war schon so ein
bisschen tue ich das wurde aber auch
nicht fest beim antworten dass der warme
8,5 okay war
dann sind genau zwischen den beiden
vorigen mal zeiten gedacht ist auf jeden
fall einen tag die sich sehen lassen
kann
das hat mir sehr viel spaß gemacht sagen
das für dich kochen durfte und enkel ist
natürlich wieder deutschland ist wie
geil ist das bedeutet dass jeden tag und
so viele neue sachen ausprobiert habe
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal zeigt
das video dokumentiert doch mal was
schönes zb sowas wie kauft ihm eine
vernünftige kamera die elendige bricht
bald kein ton ist so unfassbar
beschreibt das nochmal oder schreibt man
kommt ja okay leute sehen das nächste
mal wieder die schwören ohne
ohne video gesagt dass man sein